[Music]
keanu reeves is killing it in 2020.
in a year that's been far less than
excellent for most of the world the
beloved veteran actor has gifted us the
third bill and ted movie
bill and ted face the music he shared
exciting news about the fourth matrix
film which keanu says
is quote ambitious and has continued to
be the internet's favorite folsom movie
star
basically we'll take all the keanu we
can get thanks
on top of all that keanu is getting some
major attention for an older thriller of
his that's now dominating netflix
written and directed by eli roth the
film in question is knock knock
released in 2015 the movie didn't wow
critics when it touched down in theaters
but things have totally changed for the
overlooked thriller
which is currently burning up the charts
on everyone's go to streaming platform
as of november 5th 2020 just a few days
after knock knock was added to netflix's
library
it's the service's most popular movie in
the u.s in the film reeves plays a
happily married architect named evan
weber it's father's day weekend and evan
has the house all to himself for the
holiday
loose ends at work and an important
physical therapy appointment keep him at
home
all his wife karen and their kids head
to the beach for a family vacation
evan has a few tasks to keep him
occupied and his dog monkey to keep him
company however what would have been a
relatively uneventful weekend takes a
dark turn when two young women knock on
evan's front door
genesis and belle played by lorenza izo
and anna de armas claim they're lost and
looking for a get-together in the
neighborhood evan invites him inside so
they can hop on his computer and try to
get in touch with the host of the party
not everyone would just let two total
strangers into their house these days
well you don't look that dangerous when
the driver meant to pick up genesis and
bell arrives the women sneak off into a
bathroom inside evan's home
clearly planning to stay at his place
for a while evan makes an attempt to
kick the women out but they begin
seducing him that's when things go
seriously off the rails and evan
realizes that he's living through a
nightmare
if the basic premise of knock knock
sounds familiar it's because the feature
is a modern adaptation of the 1977 film
death game
similar to its remake death games
stumbled at the box office and received
poor reviews from critics but over the
years it's acquired a growing fan base
that includes knock-knock director roth
who revealed to collider in august 2015
that he wanted to do an updated version
of a 70s erotic thriller
he first looked to similar films from
other directors but when he came across
death game it was too good to resist
roth further explained to collider i
really wanted to do a film like a modern
fatal attraction that felt like
something that was a tense psychosexual
thriller
like the old films that roman polanski
used to make or paul verhoeven but we
just felt the story and the setup were
so good that we could do an amazing
update of it
at the time of knock knock's release on
october 2015
critics knocked it down as repetitive
and campy but now five years later it
seems that plenty of netflix subscribers
are hungry for a good distraction and
are drawn to knock knock for just how
over the top it is
well you lied to me i'm trying to help
you i let you in
i was a good guy i'm a good father at
the end of the day there are plenty of
reasons why knock knock is currently the
most popular movie on netflix in america
this streaming success should come as no
surprise to fans of reeves who managed
to snag a summer hit with bill and ted
face to music
and who is bound to break the box office
with upcoming sequels to john wick and
the matrix in production
reeves knock knock co-stars have also
scored major box office wins in recent
years
with ezo playing leonardo dicaprio's
italian starlet wife and once upon a
time in hollywood and day arma
starring as the key suspect in knives
out even though 2020 has been a
stressful year at least with knock knock
we have a little more keanu to keep his
company
it's a date movie it is a date yeah it's
like a today movie bring the two of your
girlfriends to see this
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
movies to stream on netflix are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one